welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Milan slow leak an associate
professor of political science his
research and teaching focus on
comparative politics political economy
and formal political theory professor
Volek has authored articles on the
politics of authoritarian regimes and
democratization in leading political
science journals as well as a book
entitled the politics of authoritarian
rule and the forthcoming book entitled
democratization in the age of elections
today we'll talk with professors folic
about polarization partisan conflict and
the subversion of democracy in Latin
America
welcome professor slow leak thank you
let's start with the paper you're
currently working on give us an overview
of it so the paper that I'm working on
currently is called when polarization
Trump's civic virtue and it is about the
breakdown of democracy worldwide but the
specific case is Venezuela okay the
purpose of the paper is to help us
understand why and how democracies go
from democracy back to dictatorship and
if we look at the pattern of these
breakdowns there's something interesting
that has happened since the end of the
Cold War during the Cold War and even
before the primary way in which
democracies broke down was by military
crews so this is when an extra
institutional force the military
overthrows a democratically elected
government and there are some prominent
examples of these so Pinochet's
overthrow in chilla in the early 1970s
or more recently the overthrow of
Mohamed Morsi the democratically elected
president of Egypt by the military about
two years ago but ever since the end of
the Cold War there's a different trend
so rather than military Coos the
predominant form
of what we call democratic breakdown or
an authoritarian reversal seems to be
one where it's not in the military but
rather elected incumbents who are
subverting democracy by manipulating
elections in various ways so the trend
is such that by now it is when a
democracy break that breaks down it is
two to three times more likely that it
is the incumbent who was at first
democratically elected that's obverse
democracy rather than the military
intervenes so some of the examples of
this is Vladimir Putin in Russia
Igor Chavez in Venezuela or some say
Richard Juan in Turkey okay so what gave
you the idea to look at this so one of
it is one reason for this is that we
just don't understand these forms of
democratic breakdown they were there
before but they're increasing in
frequency and they present a number of
puzzles for us and the first is that the
person in these these these
authoritarian breakdowns or executive
takeovers when they are initiated by an
incumbent they happen rarely with the
threat of force so unlike in the case of
military coups
this is somebody who was democratically
elected but who gradually starts
subverting democracy and over time
succeeds in subverting it enough so that
we no longer call the country democratic
as in the case of Russia or Venezuela or
maybe Turkey today and this is a puzzle
it seems that these incumbents are able
to take advantage of something in the
democratic process without using force
and nonetheless subvert democracy okay
let's look at a specific example do you
want to speak about Venezuela for
instance so in Venezuela Hugo Chavez
gets elected he's a very interesting
personality because before he runs for
president he actually attempts to stage
a military coup in the 90s he's
unsuccessful but before he gives up and
turns in he actually goes on the
national TV and he says this is only for
now he then gets tried imprisoned and
a pardoned and later in 1999 he actually
runs in the presidential election in
Venezuela and wins right which is
mind-boggling really right and and it
seems that this is a moment in
Venezuelan history when the population
is ready for someone new someone
different than the two-party system that
up to that point existed in Venezuela
Chavez gets elected on a platform that
is pro democratic anti-corruption and
leftist populist but gradually after
that he starts doing things that are
undemocratic in nature so he starts
gradually intimidating the opposition
intimidating journalists he starts
running a referenda that would extend
his term or more precisely that would
abolish term limits in Venezuela and
ultimately he succeeds to a point where
810 years later most political
scientists agree that Venezuela is no
longer a democratic country in fact one
fact about Venezuela that is interesting
in this context is that in political
science there's a very strong
correlation we have very few strong
correlations but one strong one is that
wealthy countries once they become
democratic they do not go back to the
container ship and Venezuela by this
standard would be the richest country
that ever was a democracy but then went
back to a dictatorship ok very you know
while you're speaking of course I'm
thinking of other correlations too for
instance of the United States with the
recent news about you know elections and
having ties from other countries
involved so I'm curious to know what
makes democracy is vulnerable to
subversion by elected incumbents so one
of the arguments that I develop in this
paper is that it is polarization
society-wide
political polarization and let's define
a term so polarization here means that
on a particularly salient political
dimension so let's say a left-right
division in society which is the case in
a Venezuela there are more individuals
at the extremes of this distribution
compared to the middle of this
distribution in other words these are
societies that lack ideological
moderates and have a lot of ideological
extremists as I mentioned this is a left
versus the right division in Venezuela
in Turkey for instance it's those who
are more secular versus those who are
more Islamist and presumably in the
United States which many claim is in
becoming increasingly polarized that
would also be primarily a left-right
ideological division okay okay so how
does how does the subversion come about
so how does polarization connect yes
exactly tential subversion of democracy
so the idea is as follows what
distinguishes polarized societies from
those who are that are not is that
partisans on one side really hate on the
other side and incumbents can take
advantage of this they understand that
precisely because of these divisions
they are able to manipulate elections
and there are many ways in which they in
which they can do this and there will be
nonetheless forgiven and the key is why
is it that they will be forgiven in
polarized societies and the answer is
that precisely because in polarized
societies supporters of one candidate
cannot possibly imagine themselves
voting for another candidate incumbents
know that if they manipulate the
democratic process and even if voters
for their own value democracy for its
own sake they will nonetheless be
reluctant to abandon the candidate they
really like for a candidate they hate
and so this creates an opportunity for
incumbents to produce a dilemma to its
to their supporters to say look I know
that you may not like the fact that I'm
manipulating the democratic process but
at the same time know that most of you
are going to stick with me in spite of
that precisely because this is a
polarized society and you like me and
you would hate to defect from me and
vote for the other candidate mm-hmm so
I'm curious to know how you're doing
your research what your methodology is
it seems kind of a tricky a tricky
business to get at people's thoughts in
this area
so I used broadly two methodologies when
I developed theory I worked with formal
models of politics so this means I tried
to develop simple mathematical models of
political interactions and then I use
predictions derived from among those
models and test them in the real world
and so in this case I did a survey in
Venezuela or I tried to get at the idea
that I just summarized that is that if
we have a polarized society then as we
get away from the middle of the
ideological distribution of voters that
is the more partisan voters are more
extreme their preferences are the more
willing they will be to tolerate
undemocratic behavior by candidates and
so one way to do this was to do what's
called a survey experiment so in a
survey I embedded a little experiment
where voters or the respondents in this
survey were choosing between two
candidates and on purpose there were
both ideological differences between
these candidates but also sometimes a
difference in the Democratic platform of
each candidate so for instance the one
forum that it took in this experiment
was that one candidate favored an
electoral commission in Venezuela that
is politically impartial so this would
be the more democratic candidate and
another candidate would be the one who
would be saying I am perfectly fine with
the electoral commission as is right now
in Venezuela which actually means it's a
very politically biased Electoral
Commission that favors the incumbent but
crucially this Democratic platform or
undemocratic platform depending on which
one we're talking about was randomized
so sometimes it was the candidate on the
left and sometimes it was the candidate
on the right who was democratic or
undemocratic and so what I'm able to do
is then compare how voters with
different intensities of partisanship
respond and say well I'm voting for this
one or that one and to what extent
voters are willing to vote for a
democratic or undemocratic candidate or
for their partisan candidate and the
crucial trade if I'm trying to get it is
when is it that voters are willing to
say well I know this candidate may not
be perfectly democratic but here's where
I stand I deal
logically and so I'm going to forgive
that and nonetheless vote for it what
about the other case where the candidate
has gone so far away from what the voter
is wanting that the voter finally says
enough so it doesn't really happen in
this experiment in part because these
candidates are artificially created by
me so what I did is I looked at what
seemed to be the main policy divisions
in Venezuela and as I mentioned this is
primarily left versus right so the
candidates on the left are socialist
candidates they're from the incumbents
party and the candidates on the right
just as in the United States they favor
less intervention by the government in
the economy less redistribution and so
on and so I own purpose to pick these
candidates so that they are very
different from each other on the
left-right dimension but nonetheless
realistic candidates that is they appeal
to these two broad coalition's within
the society so in this case we see that
both so all voters vote roughly
consistently with their ideological
preferences that is voters on the Left
vote for the candidates on the left and
voters on the right vote for the
candidate on the right but something
importance happens as we move away from
the center of the distribution of voters
so from very moderate voters to more
extremist voters and what happens is
that the moderate voters are willing to
say well maybe I'm a little bit on the
left of the middle and therefore I would
favor a candidate that's somewhat left
of the middle but when that same
candidate is actually the one who's
proposing also at the same time an
undemocratic platform then this voter
says actually I don't like that so I'm
going to vote for the candidate on the
right in other words they are willing to
put democracy first and their
partisanship only second but as we move
away from the middle so now we're
talking about extremists these
extremists they put their partisanship
first and democracy only second so in
other words if I am on the left in a
Venezuela and the extreme left it
doesn't really matter whether my
candidates proposing a democratic or
undemocratic platform they simply voting
for the candidate
and this is something that given the
intuition that isomerize before that
incumbents can take advantage of in
polarized societies a polarized society
is simply one where there's a lot of
people at the extremes and very few in
the middle and so incumbents can count
on the fact that even if they behave
undemocratically their supporters will
not abandon them out of their distaste
for for their undemocratic be right so
let's talk about the middle class and
how does that fit into your model then
so there are or does it not the middle
class all right so so the middle class
is a very tricky category in political
science because there are there's a lot
of things that that could mean and there
are famous statements in political
science like no bourgeoisie no democracy
that effectively claimed that the middle
class in some form is essential for the
survival of democracy except it's as I
said somewhat tricky because it could
mean many many things it could mean
middle income voters or it could mean a
particular class so urban voters for
instance as opposed to rural voters or
the aristocracy and in this context what
is clear that the kind of middle class
that is really important here is
ideological moderates so voters who
don't feel so strongly about either side
either party or either candidate that
they would put that above whether those
candidates are competing democratically
and so how does that play out in
Venezuela
so in Venezuela in this specific
experiment the way it plays out is
really that the more extreme you are as
a voter the more willing you in this
artificial experiment just so just on
paper okay you are willing to say yes
I'm still voting for my partisan
candidate even though I understand that
that person is less democratic than the
opposition's candidate the purpose of
this experiment is to simulate a
real-world scenario where in a real
election in Venezuela just like in this
experiment usually there are candidates
from two bloc's the incumbents blog who
are on the left and the opposition who
are on
right and so the idea is that this
experiment should show effectively that
this is the same trade off that
Venezuelan voters are making in real
life so those who are on the Left if
they are very far on the left are
ultimately saying yes I prefer democracy
to less democracy so I prefer more
democracy to less democracy but given
the difference between these two
candidates and my strong preference for
the more for the leftist candidate well
I'm going to sacrifice democracy and I
guess go for the candidate that's closer
to me ideologically or in the case of
Venezuela it's simply for the one who
redistributes more okay I'm thinking as
you're using the word democracy it could
potentially mean different things to
different people so you're developing a
model starting in Venezuela but
ultimately the model should work in
virtually any country is that correct
so cultures are so different all over
the world obviously so how do you factor
in how someone's what the word democracy
means to someone so even political
scientists disagree about the exact
criteria for what counts as a democratic
country or not and in fact the kind of
undemocratic behavior that I am talking
about is in itself a challenge for our
measurement of democracy so when an
incumbent subverts democracy rather than
it's a military that stages are cool
just like in they did in Turkey this
summer it's not a sharp sudden event it
usually happens over several electoral
cycles so the media the opposition
outside observers have a chance to point
out that undemocratic behavior under
meted undemocratic trends are happening
within a country but it's often very
gradual so it means that a journalist
may get arrested here on there or a
judge that rules in an inconvenient
fashion will get harassed by the
incumbent and in some of the more
extreme cases candidates will simply be
banned from
running or journalists and large numbers
of them can't really arrest it but
precisely because this is gradual it is
often unclear to us at which point a
country becomes so a liberal or
undemocratic that as political
scientists we are warranted in calling
these countries undemocratic so for
instance for a long time in Venezuela
people have disagreed whether ago Chavez
and what uber Chavez was doing in
Venezuela was just a new kind of
democracy maybe populist maybe a
populist democracy and at which point it
really became an undemocratic country
and this is compounded by the fact that
ever since the end of the Cold War we
have very few politicians incumbents who
when they are making these changes and
taking these undemocratic steps who
would explicitly say and that is what
I'm doing I'm on purpose making this
country less democratic much more often
what they are doing is they would say
they are working on an improvement on
democracy so Vladimir Putin in Russia
for instance talks about Russia's
sovereign democracy that is free from
the meddling by foreigners and
Westerners and in Venezuela ago Chavez
was calling his democracy Bolivarian
democracy so this was a concept that he
himself developed and the idea was that
in Venezuela under his government
democracy should combine both democratic
governments so the rule of the majority
but also redistributed elements so the
idea that democracy should be socially
just and what that meant is
redistributed wealth from the rich in
Venezuela to the poor now even in
Venezuela therefore one objection to the
study that I'm making could be that well
maybe when you are in this little survey
experiment saying that one one candidate
is less democratic than the other and I
never say that explicitly but I am
saying for instance this candidate
proposes that the electoral commission
be impartial so presumably something
that's democratic and then another
candidate will say well and I'm
proposing that we just leave the
electoral commission as is so it could
be that maybe though
voters who are voting for the second
type of candidate simply have a
different understanding of democracy and
so what I did as a part of this
experiment is actually ask voters first
so as the respondents in this survey
first well uber Chavez has championed
this idea of Bolivarian democracy what
do you associate it with and so they
were given several choices among them
the elimination of the inequalities
between the rich and poor but also more
standard understandings of democracy
such as freedom of electoral competition
civil liberties checks and balances and
so on and so these voters correctly I
think about 70% of them said yes when we
talking about Bolivar and democracy it's
definitely about reducing inequalities
between the rich and the poor but the
next question was and so which aspect of
democracy is most important for you and
their most voters say either the
competitiveness of Elections or civil
liberties or checks and balances or
political accountability only I think
about 9% say that it is the reduction of
the inequities between the rich and the
poor so it seems like in spite of all
kinds of possible confusions even
ordinary Venezuelans know that democracy
primarily means electoral competition
and that that competition should be free
and fair okay so as you're developing
this model ultimately what do you hope
to achieve so I hope to propose one way
in which we can explain why it is that
somebody like Putin in Russia or Chavez
in Venezuela aired Iran and Turkey are
at first able to get democratically
elected and then gradually and in plain
sight so as I mentioned this is not
something that happens secretly people
write about this in newspapers
journalists write about it the
opposition complains about it both at
home and abroad
and then for an observers comment on
this and nonetheless these incumbents
stay in power they gradually subvert
democracy and not only that they do so
while maintaining popularity so one
thing that's very unique
these cases is that all three of these
cases that I listed poutine Chavez air
Doan are extremely popular and they were
very popular when they got elected at
first and they remained popular so one
of the puzzles is why is it that voters
who presumably value democracy would
nonetheless vote and support candidates
who clearly are undemocratic in how they
have acted in office and the answer is
in this explanation that I'm proposing
is that in a polarized society even an
incumbent that is behaving
undemocratically you will still maintain
a significant support precisely because
it's a polarized society and so those
who support him are not going to abandon
him for a challenger because in a
polarized society there are these huge
differences between between voters and
voters are unlikely to defect to a
challenger from an incumbent that they
support very interesting and I know this
paper you're working on is part of a
larger project a larger book project
you're working on do you wanna tell us a
little bit about that so I'm currently
working on a book democratization in the
age of elections and the key idea for
the book is to explain how either
transitions to democracy or what I just
spoke about that is the breakdown of
democracy happens after the end of the
Cold War and the key distinctions there
is that whereas before the end of the
Cold War we could easily tear apart a
dictatorship from democracy by simply
asking a simple question well does that
country have elections so we had
countries like the Soviet Union that
would if have any elections this would
be such that incumbents would be the
Communist Party would be winning with 99
percent of the vote so it will be
meaningless elections and then we would
have democratic countries that would
have meaningful elections but something
that happened after the end of the Cold
War and that is connected to the trends
that I was summarizing before is that
today almost every country has some kind
of elections the few that don't have
them like Saudi Arabia or maybe China
seem like they are actually some
anachronistic cases
have been inherited from the Cold War
air but nonetheless we do have
distinctions between dictatorships and
democracies we know that electoral
competition in most of Europe and in the
United States warrants that we call
these countries democracies whereas the
kind of electoral competition that is
currently happening in Russia Venezuela
or Turkey has been so much skewed in
favor of the incumbent that we can no
longer call these countries democratic
so people have all kinds of labels for
them
people call them hybrid regimes
electoral authoritarian regimes or
competitive authoritarian regimes but
one thing that unifies them is that they
do have elections but those elections
are not competitive enough so that we
can call these countries democracies and
so what this means is that if we want to
understand transitions between democracy
and dictatorship today it is not going
to happen where we'll have a
dictatorship that doesn't have elections
and that dictatorship is at some moment
going to transition into country a
democracy that will have elections but
rather that a country that has highly
imperfect uncompetitive elections is
going to make those elections fair and
competitive and what as political
scientists we don't understand well it's
precisely what governs that transition
why is it that countries some countries
are like Russia whereas others are
perfectly competitive extremely
important work you're doing thank you
for being here with us today thank you
for more information about professor
slow leak and his research please visit
our website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
[Music]
you